okay last question what body of water do
you most identify with
a lake b river sea ocean oh that can't
be serious
of course i choose ocean i hate the
ocean that's where that stuck up [ __ ]
rose let leo die
there was plenty of room on that door
okay the computer is tabulating oh
you got category i9 c3 g6 i9
c3 g6 is that as good as it sounds
you have a robust sense of self and are
well suited to leadership positions
characteristics strength determination
tenacity yes i suppose that's accurate
they do call me tenacious ray down at
the country club
because for the past 1 years i've been
suing them for discrimination
i'm very pleased with this assessment
you should be
i took the test two and i also got an i9
c3 g6
what we got the same score it's just
crazy how accurate this thing is
yes crazy gina i was outside on business
and i purchased a box of assorted sweet
treats i give you the first pick
don't mind if i doodle curious
on your personality test you said your
favorite shape was a square
and yet now when you're given a choice
between round cookies and square
blondies you opt for
the cookie you opt for the circle yes
but it's not about shapes i'm choosing a
cookie over a blondie
i'm whimsical but i'm not a lunatic what
butter
eggs flour sugar baking soda chocolate
salt vanilla
the basic building blocks are identical
the only salient difference
the shape you're trying to get me bumped
out of i9c3g6
you don't like that the tests put us in
the same category
that is so rude do you know how many
basic [ __ ] would kill
to have the same personality as me gina
you know i appreciate you but
you have to admit we're not exactly cut
from the same cloth
apparently not i of course am exotic
silk whereas you sir
are snake skin so you can keep your box
of deception
and leave me alone it's a box of shapes
and it contains only the truth
gina i've been thinking long and hard
about what happened yesterday oh
pray tell but remember i'm not at your
level so do speak down to me
i owe you an apology the test was wrong
to classify us both as i9 c3 g6s that's
a terrible apology from content to tone
i meant i don't deserve to be an i9 c3
g6 i should be an i9 c3 g4
or an i8 c5 g3 or even an i7 c7 g8 or
i2 c1 g3 is this a rain man impression
no no those are all personality types
not well suited to leadership
just as i have not been a good leader
should never diminish those around him
it was devastating gina you're tenacious
you're strong
you're a great leader and most
importantly any basic [ __ ] would be
lucky to be like you
apology accepted can i have a huge race
no but i am expanding your
responsibilities to match your great
promise
you are now in charge of all scheduling
decisions and budget tracking
no you can do it trust me from one i9 c3
g6
to another
it's crazy how much he flirts with me
gina the d.a needs copies of our
interrogation transcripts from the
adam's case
gina gina
gina sorry i was playing crazy cupcakes
crazy cupcakes crazy with a w a
backwards w
suppose this thing is the back of the
stove yeah there is
see okay how you play you just line up
three cupcakes with the same color
frosting
and this little game of yours it's more
interesting to you than you work yeah
crazy cupcakes is a lot more interesting
than this
stop playing crazy and stop playing this
in named garbage it's embarrassing
say it to my face i did you were looking
at your phone
oh cool might be
one hot pile of boring coming in
thank you gina dismissed you're
dismissed
what you doing in here something
okay cool can i just see your phone i i
may have been
playing crazy cupcakes okay
captain i think we're past the point of
you being too proud to say the w
fine i might have been playing
crazy cupcakes it's so addictive right i
play so much that when i close my eyes
at night
i just see cupcakes now instead of my
normal dizzying array of flashing lights
yes while i have a tremendous amount of
self-control
i don't think i'll have any problem
resisting this silly game
as a matter of fact i've deleted the
application
there does does this mean i've lost my
progress
well it doesn't matter because i'm done
[Music]
have you seen captain hall tall handsome
gentleman dressed like an airline pilot
your pants are up i'm coming in
captain i think you might have a little
bit of a problem here boo
i have this under control you should
leave this is a men's room this is no
longer a men's room
it is now a liar's dead
i am captain of this precinct and you
are my assistant i have given you a
direct order to leave
i do not have a problem if i want to
play crazy cupcakes i will play
crazy cupcakes
crazy is a difficult word to say in
anger but
i think i've made my feelings clear
squad if i could have your attention
please
i'm being transferred to the public
relations office i'm leaving the 99
effective immediately what the hell
i don't understand what the hell why are
you doing this what the hell
i want to say it has been a pleasure to
have worked alongside all of you for the
past 21 and a half months
i'm sorry for getting so emotional
pretty consistent tone actually these
have been the
these have been the best years of my
career i don't know this is new
and i know that every one of you
give me everything you had
and i will never forget it go back to
being robot captain
me more see
dismissed
sir i'm coming with you
thank you gina i'm also coming not
necessary
captain the kids want to know where
paulie the pigeon is i told him he got
sucked up into an airplane engine is
that all right
i can't put that pigeonhead on gina once
has defeated me
this is how it ends with me standing on
the urine-soaked floor of an elementary
school bathroom in a third-rate
bird costume i quit no
i did not follow you to pr to watch you
quit
i followed you because you're great and
because you make everything you touch
better
and i figured pr would be the easiest
path to launching my reality show
lynnetti set go
i thought your reality show was to be
called gina in a bottle
no that was my fragrance line keep up
listen you cannot let wunch defeat you
that is not who you are you are a person
who will go out there and deliver his
eight point plan on whatever whatever
community engagement whatever even if
the only people listening
are a bunch of second graders because
captain
raymond holt never gives
up inspiring words i'm going to give
that speech
help me with that pigeon ahead yup
all right
let's blow some tiny minds let me ask
you something sir did you always have a
plan for everything you ever did you
always thought out every choice you ever
made yes by the time i was 10 i had
mapped out my entire life i knew that i
wanted to go to the academy i knew that
i wanted to become a detective
and you did it then move on to sergeant
you got it next lieutenant nailed it and
then find the captain wow
i'm convinced i think i should
reconsider my decision
uh we're not done with the game i know i
just wanted to stand so i could turn
slowly and say but wasn't there another
step
in the whole life plan gosh what was it
what came after captain i can't seem to
remember for a dramatic effect
i wanted to be commissioner gina moment
i get your point
even the best laid plans sometimes don't
work out they sure don't and now it's
time for gina's closing thoughts
just because you want to do something
doesn't mean you get to do it
life is chaos success is completely
arbitrary and confidence
is everything i was just worried
but i guess after working with you for
five years i should have realized
you know what you're doing thanks
captain
you thought this through not at all and
yet
checkmate that was completely illegal
that's not at all halloween moves that's
how this queen moves
checkmate it's against the rules of
chess well gina lynette done reinvented
the game
uh i'm supporting your overall career
decision i'm on board but you can't
assign it
i won both things chess and the argument
this little birdie
she gotta fly the coat i'm taking this
with me as a little remembrancer
you